en ukraine le front où les russes ont le
plus progressé se trouve dans le sud
autour de la mer d'azov les villes
moyennes mais litho paul hébert d'y ans
sont déjà tombés aux mains des russes et
au moment où j'enregistre cette vidéo
marioupol est assiégée et constamment
attaqués
[Musique]
en conquérant toute cette bande
littorale la mainmise des russes sur la
mer d'azov est totale mais alors
pourquoi cette si petite mer est elle si
chère aux yeux de poutine nous avons
posé la question à l'historien martin
roth responsable du cours de stratégie à
l'école de guerre
[Musique]
la mer d'azov est coincé entre la russie
et l'ukraine sa superficie est de 39
milles kilomètres carrés c'est à peu
près la taille de la suisse pour
comprendre pourquoi une si petite mer
représente un si grand enjeu il faut
regarder la place qu'elle occupe dans un
espace plus grand s'ils ont des zooms un
peu qu'ils aient la mer noire et dans un
espace encore plus grand si on désire
davantage qui et l'eurasie
historiquement le plus gros problème
géopolitique de la russie c'est que
c'est une puissance continentale
complètement enclavée à l'origine sans
aucune frontière maritime puis qui
progressivement se donne une frontière
maritime sur la baltique mais c'est une
mer fermée il y à l'océan glacial
arctique mais avant l'église glace on
pouvait rien en faire et donc la poussée
naturel si on peut dire ça ça va être
vers le sud est justement vers la
bernois et cette stratégie de marche
vers le sud pour aller dans les mers
chaudes c'est un conseiller de pierre
legrand qu'il a formalisé le premier
dans un texte de 1725 présenté comme le
testament de pierre le grand ce tsar
russe et le modèle et héros de vladimir
poutine et dans ce texte on peut lire
les lignes suivantes
approcher le plus possible de
constantinople c'est à dire aujourd'hui
istanbul et des indes celui qui règnera
sur un livret souverains du monde en
conséquence sans pareil soit à peu de la
mer noire
pénétré jusqu'au golfe persique aïda mer
noire c'est évidemment la route pour les
russes pour aller en méditerranée et de
la houle persique rétablir par la syrie
ancien commerce du levant en vous
ajoutez mer noire et syrie compte tenu
de l'histoire de ces cinq dernières
années évidemment ça fait sens et
avancez jusqu aux ânes fin 19e deux
granges et aux politiciens occidentaux
viennent en quelque sorte valider la
théorie prêté à pierre le grand il
s'agit d'abord d'alfred man dans son
livre le problème de l'asie manille
oppose la russie puissance continentale
à la grande bretagne puissance maritime
et cette puissance maritime à l'époque
contrôle finalement le littoral sud de
l'eurasie puisqu'elle contrôle le
détroit de gibraltar à contrôler malte
contrôle le canal de suez du canal de
suez par la mer rouge contre laden de là
ils se projettent dans l'océan indien
elle possède l'inde et puis ensuite par
mala par le détroit de malacca elle
arrive à ses comptoirs de schille du
coup elle le bénéficie finalement des
flux commerciaux mondiaux émane explique
que le problème de la russie c'est de ne
pas avoir accès à ces flux commerciaux
donc d'avoir un retard au développement
pieds liés à cette à cette nonne
ouverture sur la mer d'où une tendance
de la russie que mal justifie sur le
plan géopolitique tout en disant qu'il
faut s'y opposer a donc forcé le passage
vers le sud et mandy bien l'endroit où
il est le plus simple de forcer le
passage vers le sud c'est évidemment la
mer noire parce que c'est là que la
masse continentale russe est le plus
proche des moeurs libres un an après
l'exposé de mme anne alfort john
mackinder en remet une couche en pubiens
son article sur le pivot géographique de
l'histoire où il montre cette carte du
monde une grande partie de la russie
composent ce qu'il appelle le farc
landes terres continentales en
pointillés sur la carte vient ensuite
une autre zone le sud de l'eurasie une
zone qui bordent les littoraux et qu'il
appelle le croissant intérieur sur cette
représentation du monde on voit que la
mer noire se trouve pile à l'interface
de ces deux ensembles elle permet à la
russie de s'ouvrir sur le croissant
intérieur maintenant qu'on a vu toute
l'importance stratégique symbolique et
historique que représente la mer noire
pour les russes intéressons-nous de plus
près à la mer qui nous intéresse la mer
d'azov si vous regardez à quoi ils
ressemblent vous avez l'impression que
c'est c'est une mère pratiquement fermé
ya ce petit détroit de kertch large de 5
km qui séparent les deux rives bon donc
ça fait comme une espèce de deux
bastions facile à défendre pour qu'ils
contrôlent toutes les rives intérieur
puisqu'il ya un petit des trois a fermé
et ce bestiau idée sur le flanc oriental
de la crimée et donc qui permet de
consolider la mamie ce qu'on a sur la
grille mais
il est pratiquement clair maintenant que
l'un des buts de guerre de poutine et
donc d'annexer les rivages de cette mer
d'azov afin de permettre la jonction
territorial entre la russie et la crimée
et protéger cette péninsule un épisode
de l'histoire montre tout l'intérêt de
contrôler cette zone il se déroule
pendant la guerre de crimée pendant les
années 1850 qui oppose à la turquie aidé
de la france et de la grande-bretagne à
la russie alors en 1854 les français et
les britanniques assiègent sébastopol
qui est le grand port de crimée la
grande base navale russe et sébastopol
va tenir pendant un an entre autres
choses parce que n'est pas entièrement
bouclé par les franco britannique et il
y à du ravitaillement qui arrivent
encore à rentrer dedans et devient ce
ravitaillement il vient de la mer d'azov
parce que la mer d'azov passé entre
autres choses il ya le fleuve d'onde qui
se jette dans la mer d'azov donc très
facile d'amener par challans des
céréales qui viennent des grandes
plaines russes et donc de la de les
acheminer sur la côte de la crimée
débarqué nuitamment et d'approvisionner
sébastopol mais il n'ya pas que les
céréales que l'on peut acheminer dans
cet espace sur le plan militaire il y à
un autre enjeu beaucoup plus actuelle à
posséder cette mer d'azov pour
comprendre cela je dois d'abord vous
parlez de la mer caspienne une mer
intérieure n'ayant aucun débouché sur
les mers du sud est situé un peu plus à
l'est
en 2015 lors de la guerre menée en syrie
par les russes des missiles ont été
tirés sur des candidats est depuis cette
mer caspienne la mer caspienne qui
stratégiquement ne servait pas à grand
chose est devenue un espace d'évolution
dans des bâtiments russes peuvent tirer
des missiles or cette mer caspienne quel
est le canal qui la relie au reste du
système des canaux des soviétiques et
bien c'est un canal qui joue à la mer
caspienne à la mer d'azov en mettant la
main sur la mer d'azov la russie est
désormais libre de faire transiter ses
navires de guerre d'une mer à l'autre de
la mer noire à la mer caspienne via la
mer d'azov et le canal dans le gard
pourquoi pourquoi c'est intéressant
d'avoir des navigants parce que le
navire il est tout le temps en mouvement
donc le localiser pour les lycées
difficiles et le navire c'est donc une
batterie de missiles qui évolue en
permanence qui change des positions et
donc difficiles à fond
dans cet article paru en 2016 dans la
revue défense nationale le capitaine de
frégate prairial an analyse cette
nouvelle stratégie navale russe je cite
reliés par le canal donne volga les de
mer caspienne et noir offre un espace de
manoeuvre équivalent à la méditerranée
orientale et au golfe arabo-persique
réunit la carte des portes et des
missiles calibre montre que la russie
est sur le point d'acquérir la capacité
d'opérer selon et politique de la
canonnière sur un théâtre de 6000 km de
long sans recourir à un accès aux mers
chaudes cet espace recouvre une
trentaine de pays comprenant la sphère
d'influencé actuelle les marges
historiques de l'empiré russe et les
lieux de rivalités politiques ou
énergétiques actuelles c'est une
véritable révolution géopolitique
puisque ça ça casse en quelque sorte que
ça relativise au moins la distinction
classique en géopolitique entre la masse
continentale qui peut pas intervenir
dans la guerre navale et le monde
maritime les russes ont finalement
développé ce qu'il appelle une puissance
navale continentale et
la mer d'azov du fait qu'elle fait bien
avec la caspienne s'inscrit de plain
pied dans cette stratégie navale
continental
[Musique]
g